on jongo is a Himba dance it looks as if
Zuma caturanga belongs here but in some
ways this namibian is different the 29
year old works for the state TV
broadcaster in the captial wind hook he
trained there to become a lighting
technician Zuma caturanga is the only
member of his family who went to school
and learn to trade the Himba tribe
member has worked at the NBC studios for
over five years and for five years his
world has been the modern world of the
capital with its shopping malls
infrastructure and restaurants any extra
money he has goes to his family
sometimes he pays a visit to his people
in a poor write up in northern Namibia
it takes a whole day for Zuma to reach
his village he hasn't seen his family
for three months before he sees them he
needs to change his look now I have to
change into my traditional clothes and
get rid of this city seedy laughing yeah
so that I can keep my anger and go to
the holy fire otherwise I'm not gonna
eat or drink anything here down at home
that's why I have all this along with
traditional dress a ferric oxide paste
is applied to his skin it's a mix of
finely ground red sandstone and beef fat
it'll protect him against the Sun and is
a tribal tradition every homecoming is a
celebration and today is no exception
except this time his uncle has a
surprise for him in a tribal ceremony
Zuma is being married off his uncle has
more influence than Zoomers parents he's
considered an elder and a powerful
figure oh well here is the boy he's been
married in accordance with our tradition
he came home to marry I will give him
this jar of milk to drink from he's gone
and he has returned I've married them
now he has a wife he has his wife he is
married then we walk when you get a
whimper but yeah his new wife is also
his cousin that's another tradition
among the himba Oh
like a nightmare another hate to go
through right like now I don't know like
something hot like nightmare that I have
enough to go through it to see how do I
have to explain to the person that I've
been with down in the city back to the
modern world in town Zoomer lives with a
partner a woman he also wants to marry
he's worried his partner in town will
have little understanding for his
situation I really can let the go like
this yeah I hope maybe she have
something at the back of her mind that
she's not when I tell me now that is
maybe when to tell me later
and I hope everything will remain the
same
I forbid it
someone was been me for almost two years
to be told that it is scary he's getting
ready to someone else I felt it
when I'd was brewing you especially the
first time giving even many different
beliefs you know if the life is going to
be [ __ ] bunk sickles people I don't
listen
I realize nothing wood chips perhaps uma
will be able to reconcile his two lives
and when you get down here you forget
macaroni was the himba tradition allows
a man to have several wives gender roles
are clearly defined hmm
we get it on him you do it we got B me
Bobby and bizarre told from a young age
that one day we'll marry our cousins we
just have to agree even if you don't
want to you have to marry your cousin
yeah and then you stay home with your
uncle's or aunts and then we're gonna
hang out with each boy long before dawn
this is the handle way we marry among
ourselves
one day time but now we do ruin this is
the pressure that I have been living
since my childhood since I started
school because I have to balance my my
life beauty to lives yeah I don't have
another option and something that I have
to face is the life that I've been
raised a life because I'm living to life
this is the life in my my original life
where I come from
Zuma caturanga doesn't yet know if his
life will change for the better or for
the worse
but he does know that he will always go
back to his people
the Himba